the following content is provided under a Creative Commons license your support
a Creative Commons license your support will help MIT open courseware continue
will help MIT open courseware continue to offer highquality educational
to offer highquality educational resources for free to make a donation or
resources for free to make a donation or view additional materials from hundreds
view additional materials from hundreds of MIT courses visit MIT open courseware
of MIT courses visit MIT open courseware at
ocw.mit.edu Eric and I have been tag teaming this lecturing this class so
teaming this lecturing this class so we're going to split this
we're going to split this lecture so I get to do uh the first uh
lecture so I get to do uh the first uh two
two minutes no I I get I get to do the first
minutes no I I get I get to do the first uh 20 minutes or so uh talking about
uh 20 minutes or so uh talking about some of my research in parallel
some of my research in parallel architecture and Eric's going to talk
architecture and Eric's going to talk about a bunch of things that he's been
about a bunch of things that he's been up to over the years in an algorithm
up to over the years in an algorithm design and
design and Analysis so let's get
started when was the first uh PC built anybody
yeah no the first personal computer was 1981 the not the first computer right so
1981 the not the first computer right so um all of you know about uh Intel and
um all of you know about uh Intel and Microsoft and IBM and so
Microsoft and IBM and so on uh
on uh Intel's you know gift to humankind is
Intel's you know gift to humankind is the x86 architecture though some people
the x86 architecture though some people would argue that point
would argue that point but and the x86 architecture was in
but and the x86 architecture was in invented in 1981 and was part of the
invented in 1981 and was part of the first PC that provided the horse power
first PC that provided the horse power for the first PC the IBM PC and it ran
for the first PC the IBM PC and it ran at 5
at 5 megahertz
okay and x86 has been around you still can buy x86 computers the
can buy x86 computers the 8486 in
8486 in 1989 ran at 25 MHz
1989 ran at 25 MHz so you can see a trend
so you can see a trend here and the 8486 as it turns out ended
here and the 8486 as it turns out ended up being called the i486 because there
up being called the i486 because there was a code ruling that said that you
was a code ruling that said that you couldn't trademark numbers and so Intel
couldn't trademark numbers and so Intel at that point decided to start naming
at that point decided to start naming their
their processors so the Pentium which is one
processors so the Pentium which is one of the more famous Intel processors was
of the more famous Intel processors was built and came out in
built and came out in 1993 and the clock speed went up to 66
1993 and the clock speed went up to 66 MHz back in the early '90s
MHz back in the early '90s and since this was just such a cool
and since this was just such a cool name Intel continued to call its
name Intel continued to call its processors Pentium
processors Pentium and the Pentium 4 in
and the Pentium 4 in 2000 had this incredibly deep pipeline
2000 had this incredibly deep pipeline where you broke up the computation into
where you broke up the computation into a bunch of stages in fact it had a 30
a bunch of stages in fact it had a 30 stage Pipeline and so the clock speed
stage Pipeline and so the clock speed went up all the way to 1.5
went up all the way to 1.5 GHz the Pentium was famous for many
GHz the Pentium was famous for many things including a couple of bugs in the
things including a couple of bugs in the floating Point pipeline where
floating Point pipeline where division in particular Corner
division in particular Corner cases wasn't done correctly and there
cases wasn't done correctly and there was also this bug called the f00 F
was also this bug called the f00 F bug which
bug which allowed a malicious program to crash the
allowed a malicious program to crash the entire system regardless of whether it
entire system regardless of whether it had administrative privileges or
had administrative privileges or not but the Pentium was obviously very
not but the Pentium was obviously very successful lot of machine
successful lot of machine sold and it felt like it was only going
sold and it felt like it was only going to be a matter of time before we got to
to be a matter of time before we got to tens of gigahertz the way things were
tens of gigahertz the way things were going as you can see this is a pretty
going as you can see this is a pretty steep growth from 5 MHz to 25 to 1.5
steep growth from 5 MHz to 25 to 1.5 gahz in the space of about 20
gahz in the space of about 20 years um as it turns
years um as it turns out
out after the Pentium D which came out in
after the Pentium D which came out in 2005 where the clock speed peaked at
2005 where the clock speed peaked at about 3.2 GHz clock frequency stopped
about 3.2 GHz clock frequency stopped increasing and what you see
increasing and what you see now are things that correspond to
now are things that correspond to multiple processors on a chip so for
multiple processors on a chip so for example the quad cord
example the quad cord Zeon came out in 2008 you can still buy
Zeon came out in 2008 you can still buy it only runs at 3 GHz which is
it only runs at 3 GHz which is basically about the same as the Pentium
basically about the same as the Pentium D Ram each of these has a range of
D Ram each of these has a range of frequencies
frequencies and Beyond about 2005 the clock speed of
and Beyond about 2005 the clock speed of processors that you can buy is kind of
processors that you can buy is kind of saturated at at about 3 GHz and the way
saturated at at about 3 GHz and the way you're getting performance is by putting
you're getting performance is by putting multiple processors on the chip and
multiple processors on the chip and people use the term
people use the term cores synonymously with processors so a
cores synonymously with processors so a quad core means that they're in effect
quad core means that they're in effect four x86 processors on the same silicon
four x86 processors on the same silicon integrated circuit and they're
integrated circuit and they're interconnected together and they talk to
interconnected together and they talk to memory and you have essentially a
memory and you have essentially a parallel processor on a single
parallel processor on a single chip and a single user potentially
chip and a single user potentially running many programs is using this
running many programs is using this system and you have dual core processors
system and you have dual core processors on your laptops and so the scale now is
on your laptops and so the scale now is or the metric now I should say
or the metric now I should say is how many cores do you have on a chip
is how many cores do you have on a chip and people are predicting that we're
and people are predicting that we're going to have a th000 cores by 2020 on a
going to have a th000 cores by 2020 on a chip so this brings us to the problem of
chip so this brings us to the problem of how do we use parallelism so there's a
how do we use parallelism so there's a lot of work on Parallel algorithms
lot of work on Parallel algorithms there's also work in building Hardware
there's also work in building Hardware such that algorithms can sort of
such that algorithms can sort of automatically be paralyzed while they're
automatically be paralyzed while they're running in Hardware so they can run
running in Hardware so they can run faster and so on and so forth so some of
faster and so on and so forth so some of my research is in parallel architectures
my research is in parallel architectures some of it is in parallel algorithms I
some of it is in parallel algorithms I want to give you a sense of what the
want to give you a sense of what the problems are in building parallel
problems are in building parallel architectures and in particular I'll
architectures and in particular I'll start with a canonical system that
start with a canonical system that corresponds to let's say this quad core
corresponds to let's say this quad core system and so you have four
system and so you have four processors on this single integrated
processors on this single integrated circuit so that signifies that and
circuit so that signifies that and typically you have a lot of fast static
typically you have a lot of fast static Random Access Memory SRAM on the same
Random Access Memory SRAM on the same chip so typically megabytes of of memory
chip so typically megabytes of of memory on the Chip And gigabytes of memory in
on the Chip And gigabytes of memory in Dam which are separate modules that are
Dam which are separate modules that are connected via a high-speed bus off the
connected via a high-speed bus off the chip so
chip so that's there usually many dram modules
that's there usually many dram modules they're called dims uh if you might have
they're called dims uh if you might have heard that term so the connection
heard that term so the connection between
between the processors and the SRAM is typically
the processors and the SRAM is typically very fast it's on chip things being
very fast it's on chip things being clocked at at gahz and when you go off
clocked at at gahz and when you go off chip you're down to a few hundred
chip you're down to a few hundred megaherz so typically in order of
megaherz so typically in order of magnitude less speed but you're
magnitude less speed but you're accessing much more memory so this is
accessing much more memory so this is really gigabytes and this is at the
really gigabytes and this is at the level of
megabytes if you see this picture here if you think about the number of
here if you think about the number of processors increasing from four to 8 to
processors increasing from four to 8 to 16 in all the way say to hundreds of
16 in all the way say to hundreds of processors um you can see that there's
processors um you can see that there's going to be a bottleneck associated with
going to be a bottleneck associated with accessing the memory the big problem is
accessing the memory the big problem is you can't possibly build memory that
you can't possibly build memory that serves hundreds of requests in parallel
serves hundreds of requests in parallel if you try and make a large SRAM which
if you try and make a large SRAM which is megabytes long the number of ports in
is megabytes long the number of ports in the SRAM read
ports is you know roughly of the order of four and after that it's kind of hard
of four and after that it's kind of hard to build right so this architecture
to build right so this architecture isn't going
isn't going to be sustainable Beyond
to be sustainable Beyond 48 maybe 16 cores so typically what
48 maybe 16 cores so typically what people build is or people are trying to
people build is or people are trying to build in Academia is something that
build in Academia is something that corresponds to a distributed
corresponds to a distributed architecture on the chip
architecture on the chip where you have processors and memory in
where you have processors and memory in tiles so you
have essentially something like this where you could imagine
where you could imagine having literally 100 processors on a
having literally 100 processors on a chip that correspond
chip that correspond to an implementation where you build
to an implementation where you build tiles where you have a processor that's
tiles where you have a processor that's doing the computation and you have
doing the computation and you have memory and it's sometimes called cache
memory and it's sometimes called cache memory but there's multiple levels of
memory but there's multiple levels of caches typically that are attached to
caches typically that are attached to each of these processors and
each of these processors and the space between the processor tiles
the space between the processor tiles is reserved
is reserved for interconnect or for wires that
for interconnect or for wires that connect these processors up and so
connect these processors up and so there's research that goes on in routing
there's research that goes on in routing algorithms how do you figure out if
algorithms how do you figure out if these processors want to talk to each
these processors want to talk to each other um what the best way of routing
other um what the best way of routing the messages are you want to find the
the messages are you want to find the shortest path in this case the weight
shortest path in this case the weight corresponds to the congestion that's
corresponds to the congestion that's associated with each of these channels
associated with each of these channels that you have and people actually use
that you have and people actually use algorithms like weighted shortest paths
algorithms like weighted shortest paths in Hardware to determine what the best
in Hardware to determine what the best way of getting from here to there is it
way of getting from here to there is it may not be this way it may be going
may not be this way it may be going around the chip simply because that path
around the chip simply because that path the latter one is less
the latter one is less congested um the other issue that comes
congested um the other issue that comes up has to do with um how long it takes
up has to do with um how long it takes to go across the chip and come back so
to go across the chip and come back so if this processor wants to access its
if this processor wants to access its local memory that's typically typically
local memory that's typically typically pretty simple or fast but if it wants to
pretty simple or fast but if it wants to access remote memory and it's quite
access remote memory and it's quite possible that it's sharing some data
possible that it's sharing some data with a different thread running on a
with a different thread running on a different processor so typically there's
different processor so typically there's a program running on this processor some
a program running on this processor some sometimes called a thread and this
sometimes called a thread and this program may share data with a with with
program may share data with a with with a different program which is running on
a different program which is running on on this processor or it may just require
on this processor or it may just require a lot more space and what this program
a lot more space and what this program has to do is is make a request all the
has to do is is make a request all the way to this
way to this processor um and this particular cache
processor um and this particular cache in this processor and then it gets the
in this processor and then it gets the data
data back so what you see here is a round
back so what you see here is a round trip access that goes across the Chip
trip access that goes across the Chip And
And this distance if it's large could take
this distance if it's large could take tens of Cycles so typically it's a
tens of Cycles so typically it's a single cycle to access local memory the
single cycle to access local memory the fastest local memory called the L1 cache
fastest local memory called the L1 cache but it could take tens of Cycles to go
but it could take tens of Cycles to go send a message across the chip and tens
send a message across the chip and tens of Cycles to get the data back so the
of Cycles to get the data back so the bottleneck really in parallel processing
bottleneck really in parallel processing from a standpoint of communication is
from a standpoint of communication is this routing of messages and getting the
this routing of messages and getting the messages
messages back one of the things that my research
back one of the things that my research group is doing is looking at the notion
group is doing is looking at the notion of migrating computation as opposed to
of migrating computation as opposed to data we call it execution
data we call it execution migration
migration where you could you could say suppose I
where you could you could say suppose I have a processor
have a processor running a particular program out here
running a particular program out here and if this program wanted to access a
and if this program wanted to access a remote
remote memory then rather than doing what I
memory then rather than doing what I just showed you there send a message get
just showed you there send a message get the data back you could imagine that you
the data back you could imagine that you could migrate the program itself and in
could migrate the program itself and in particular you think of it as migrating
particular you think of it as migrating the context of the
the context of the program
program from this processor to this one and so
from this processor to this one and so what is the context for those of you in
what is the context for those of you in who have taken
who have taken 64 probably know what this is but
64 probably know what this is but it's
it's simply where you are in terms of
simply where you are in terms of executing your program and that's
executing your program and that's typically given to you by our program
typically given to you by our program counter and your current state of your
counter and your current state of your register
register file and a few other things
file and a few other things including uh cache memory and so on and
including uh cache memory and so on and so forth so the advantage with execution
so forth so the advantage with execution migration is that it's a oneway trip as
migration is that it's a oneway trip as opposed to a round
trip um you don't have to send a message and
um you don't have to send a message and get the data back which would be two
get the data back which would be two messages if you will one in the case of
messages if you will one in the case of the address and the other for the data
the address and the other for the data but you migrate your execution and you
but you migrate your execution and you run since you have computation out here
run since you have computation out here you can run on this remote processor uh
you can run on this remote processor uh so that's one of the advantages of
so that's one of the advantages of execution migration one of the downsides
execution migration one of the downsides of it is that
of it is that this is can be multiple kilo bytes or
this is can be multiple kilo bytes or kilobits and it could be significantly
kilobits and it could be significantly more in terms of size or in terms of
more in terms of size or in terms of bits than the data that you want to
bits than the data that you want to access so there's a bit of there's a
access so there's a bit of there's a trade-off here and then when anytime you
trade-off here and then when anytime you have a trade-off well you can think of
have a trade-off well you can think of an algorithm to try and find the optimal
an algorithm to try and find the optimal trade-off so this is the context for the
trade-off so this is the context for the particular optimization problem that we
particular optimization problem that we need to solve here that corresponds to
need to solve here that corresponds to really dis deciding when you want to do
really dis deciding when you want to do data migration and when you want to do
data migration and when you want to do execution
execution migration right there's a choice um at
migration right there's a choice um at the top
the top level um it's a round trip to get the
level um it's a round trip to get the data so you're really
data so you're really traveling longer twice as long or the
traveling longer twice as long or the distance is twice as much but it's
distance is twice as much but it's possible that the amount of state that
possible that the amount of state that you'd have to
you'd have to move in terms of taking your context if
move in terms of taking your context if you're a spr and moving across the chip
you're a spr and moving across the chip could be large enough that it offsets
could be large enough that it offsets the advantage of the shorter distance
the advantage of the shorter distance all right so we can set this up as an an
all right so we can set this up as an an optimization problem so now we're in the
optimization problem so now we're in the realm of we moved from 64 to 66 here in
realm of we moved from 64 to 66 here in the last couple of seconds so assume we
the last couple of seconds so assume we know or can
of a program and you can do this people build these things in Hardware prefetch
build these things in Hardware prefetch engines branch predictors and so on
engines branch predictors and so on they're in the the x86 machines and you
they're in the the x86 machines and you can tell especially if you're going
can tell especially if you're going through a loop over and over you can
through a loop over and over you can make this prediction but so you have
make this prediction but so you have some amount of look ahead and you know
some amount of look ahead and you know that uh M1 through MN are the memory
that uh M1 through MN are the memory accesses that this program is going to
accesses that this program is going to make
make and these are the memory
addresses and I'm going to think about P of M1 P of
of M1 P of M2 P of
M2 P of MN as the the
MN as the the processor
processor caches for each
caches for each Mi
Mi so what might be the case in a simple
so what might be the case in a simple example is
example is you you want to access memory in
you you want to access memory in processor one you're sitting there you
processor one you're sitting there you want to access memory in processor one
want to access memory in processor one and then the next one you want to access
and then the next one you want to access memory and processor to and so on and so
memory and processor to and so on and so forth so you might see something like
forth so you might see something like that so the sequence of memory addresses
that so the sequence of memory addresses um if you're sitting on processor one
um if you're sitting on processor one this first one is local and then after
this first one is local and then after that you want to access processor 2's
that you want to access processor 2's memory because you're sharing data with
memory because you're sharing data with it then you're back home again to
it then you're back home again to processor one and so on and so forth all
processor one and so on and so forth all right um so
right um so that's one example of a setup and we can
that's one example of a setup and we can think about the cost of
think about the cost of migration as if you want to go from s to
migration as if you want to go from s to d as being a function of the distance s
d as being a function of the distance s comma D plus some
comma D plus some constant which
constant which is proportional to the uh the Contex
is proportional to the uh the Contex size and that context size we're going
size and that context size we're going to assume is fixed for a particular
to assume is fixed for a particular architecture
architecture it may change for different
it may change for different architectures but if it's a few kilobits
architectures but if it's a few kilobits um then there's going to be some
um then there's going to be some overhead associated with putting the
overhead associated with putting the context onto the network and it's a
context onto the network and it's a sizable overhead that needs to be taken
sizable overhead that needs to be taken into
into account that's the cost of migration the
account that's the cost of migration the cost of an
cost of an access S comma D is twice the
access S comma D is twice the distance between s and d and it's
distance between s and d and it's typically a just a word that you want to
typically a just a word that you want to access 32 bit 6 four Bits And so there's
access 32 bit 6 four Bits And so there's no additional overhead associated with
no additional overhead associated with data access so there you go you
data access so there you go you have uh the formulation of the problem
have uh the formulation of the problem you have the tradeoff written where the
you have the tradeoff written where the cost of migration
cost of migration has just the distance but it has a
has just the distance but it has a constant factor and you got twice the
constant factor and you got twice the distance here for the
distance here for the access right now if s equals D and I
access right now if s equals D and I want to write this down U you have a
want to write this down U you have a local access and and the cost is assumed
local access and and the cost is assumed to be zero right you could change that
to be zero right you could change that this is now we're in the realm of of
this is now we're in the realm of of theory and symbols so you can do
theory and symbols so you can do whatever you want um but given those
whatever you want um but given those equations our
equations our problem is
problem is decide
decide when to
minimize total memory access cost
so in our example there suppose we had P1
P1 P2 P2
P1 this first one would be a local access and then you may decide that you
access and then you may decide that you want to migrate to P2 over
here in which case you get this is a local axis as well so is this one right
local axis as well so is this one right here you might want to migrate to P1
here you might want to migrate to P1 back to
P1 so this becomes a local access that's a local access they're all essentially
a local access they're all essentially free and then if you just stay at P1
free and then if you just stay at P1 over here you may end up doing remote
over here you may end up doing remote accesses to P3 and P2
accesses to P3 and P2 respectively and so you have a cost of
respectively and so you have a cost of migration cost of migration and the cost
migration cost of migration and the cost of two remote accesses all right
of two remote accesses all right so that's the setup how are we going to
so that's the setup how are we going to solve this
problem are we going to use dyra are we going to use belman Ford are we going to
going to use belman Ford are we going to use balance search trees are we going to
use balance search trees are we going to use hash functions what are we going to
use hash functions what are we going to use dynamic programming all
use dynamic programming all together dynamic programming all right
together dynamic programming all right we're going to use dynamic programming
we're going to use dynamic programming to solve this problem okay uh good so
to solve this problem okay uh good so Eric thought brought you
Eric thought brought you something where are the erasers yeah
something where are the erasers yeah where are the erasers I think they're
where are the erasers I think they're fallen down here all right let's uh let
fallen down here all right let's uh let me um bail out and use this while you
me um bail out and use this while you find the erasers
find the erasers um so program at P1 which is the
um so program at P1 which is the processor initially okay I'm just going
processor initially okay I'm just going to set up this DP problem let's assume
to set up this DP problem let's assume that the number of
processors equals Q
Q um now what are the sub
problems the you could do this many different
different ways let's go ahead and use
ways let's go ahead and use prefixes and so DP
prefixes and so DP kp1 is the
kp1 is the cost of the
cost of the optimal
prefix M1 through
M1 through MK of memory
accesses when the program starts at P1 and ends
at Pi so that's my sub problem I want to I
Pi so that's my sub problem I want to I want to know as I build this up um what
want to know as I build this up um what is the optimal way that I'm going to
is the optimal way that I'm going to choose between migrations and accesses
choose between migrations and accesses for the first k memory axises assuming a
for the first k memory axises assuming a starting point at
P1 and ending at some some pi and I need to build up these sub problems and I
to build up these sub problems and I want to grow them okay so let's go ahead
want to grow them okay so let's go ahead and set this
and set this up um what I want to do now is figure
up um what I want to do now is figure out DP k+ one
out DP k+ one PJ and assuming I have all of the kpis
PJ and assuming I have all of the kpis computed and how many sub problems do I
computed and how many sub problems do I have how many sub problems do I
have how many sub problems do I have
have total look at this and tell me what the
total look at this and tell me what the ranges of the possibilities are so how
ranges of the possibilities are so how many sub problems would I have
someone y n * uh Q yep right so you have n * Q sub
problems so um you've set this up for up until K
so um you've set this up for up until K and for all of the pis now what you have
and for all of the pis now what you have to do is essentially say well DP of k +
to do is essentially say well DP of k + 1 PJ is going to be K PJ
Plus cost of
of access PJ P of MK +
access PJ P of MK + 1
1 if PJ is not equal to P of MK + 1 right
if PJ is not equal to P of MK + 1 right so there's going to be two cases I'll
so there's going to be two cases I'll just write this out and I'll explain
just write this out and I'll explain it but the first case corresponds to if
it but the first case corresponds to if the new memory access is not in the
the new memory access is not in the processor cache corresponding to PJ then
processor cache corresponding to PJ then what you have what you could do is um
what you have what you could do is um use the optimum value where you end at
use the optimum value where you end at PJ and simply do a remote access uh that
PJ and simply do a remote access uh that corresponds to accessing MK + one so
corresponds to accessing MK + one so that's one case the other case is to
use the minimum solution Optimum solution corresponding
solution Optimum solution corresponding to ending at
pi and do a migration you have caused a migration from PI to
migration from PI to PJ and you do this
if you want to go to P of MK + 1 the the processor corresponding to P of MK + 1
processor corresponding to P of MK + 1 so that's this that's the setup for this
so that's this that's the setup for this Dynamic
Dynamic program um what you've done is created a
program um what you've done is created a sub problem it's Optimum and then you
sub problem it's Optimum and then you have you look at the two two cases do
have you look at the two two cases do you want to go migrate and and do a
you want to go migrate and and do a local access that's this case over here
local access that's this case over here right migrate to the processor and do a
right migrate to the processor and do a local access there that would be this
local access there that would be this case and in this case you stay where you
case and in this case you stay where you are and do a remote access and um in the
are and do a remote access and um in the case of migration you could end
case of migration you could end up uh choosing different initial points
up uh choosing different initial points starting points corresponding to the pis
starting points corresponding to the pis and you have to run through all of those
and you have to run through all of those all right so what's the cost
all right so what's the cost of a sub problem or the running time of
of a sub problem or the running time of of computing one of these things it's
of computing one of these things it's order
order q and so the total
cost is NQ
is NQ s all
s all right it's a little
right it's a little uh review of uh DP um I'm GNA stop here
uh review of uh DP um I'm GNA stop here and and let Eric take over um just in
and and let Eric take over um just in closing um while this you know makes
closing um while this you know makes some assumptions it's actually
some assumptions it's actually fairly close to what we're building in
fairly close to what we're building in Hardware this type of analysis is
Hardware this type of analysis is something that we have to do in Hardware
something that we have to do in Hardware my research group is building a 128
my research group is building a 128 processor M machine that we call the
processor M machine that we call the execution migration machine and it does
execution migration machine and it does exactly what I've described to you
exactly what I've described to you decide whether to do a remote access or
decide whether to do a remote access or to do a migration based on this kind of
to do a migration based on this kind of analys is all right so hand it over to
analys is all right so hand it over to Eric mic all
Eric mic all right
right uh so I have a few things to uh tell you
uh so I have a few things to uh tell you a little bit about shy talked about one
a little bit about shy talked about one Topic in detail I'm going to talk about
Topic in detail I'm going to talk about many topics in less detail as I said
many topics in less detail as I said shallowly um and the these are my main
shallowly um and the these are my main areas of research I do geometry in
areas of research I do geometry in particular folding and data structures
particular folding and data structures graphs and recreational algorithms
graphs and recreational algorithms that's the really fun stuff and a lot of
that's the really fun stuff and a lot of these have corresponding courses if
these have corresponding courses if you're interested in more about this
you're interested in more about this stuff computational geometry in general
stuff computational geometry in general is uh oh I'm not going to remember all
is uh oh I'm not going to remember all the
the numbers eight 40
numbers eight 40 50
50 50
50 6850 that's a class I don't teach uh
6850 that's a class I don't teach uh folding is
folding is 6849 uh data structures is
6849 uh data structures is 6851 and
6851 and graphs was being taught this semester in
graphs was being taught this semester in parallel with this class
parallel with this class 6889 and recreational
6889 and recreational algorithms isn't fully covered but you
algorithms isn't fully covered but you could check out SP 268 which was offered
could check out SP 268 which was offered last semester and especially for those
last semester and especially for those watching at home in on MIT open
watching at home in on MIT open courseware uh this class all the video
courseware uh this class all the video lectures are online for free uh 6851
lectures are online for free uh 6851 will do that next semester and 6889 are
will do that next semester and 6889 are all online right now and there's some
all online right now and there's some lecture notes for SP 268 on open
lecture notes for SP 268 on open courseware so uh there's a lot of
courseware so uh there's a lot of material here and in particular the the
material here and in particular the the obvious next class for you to be taking
obvious next class for you to be taking is
is 6046 but why should you be taking 6046
6046 but why should you be taking 6046 because then you can take all these
because then you can take all these exciting classes and many others about
exciting classes and many others about algorithms there's a complete list of
algorithms there's a complete list of follow-on classes in the lecture notes
follow-on classes in the lecture notes uh which are online and there there's a
uh which are online and there there's a ton of I mean there's so much research
ton of I mean there's so much research in algorithms it's a really exciting
in algorithms it's a really exciting area this is just the beginning just the
area this is just the beginning just the taste and I want to show you where very
taste and I want to show you where very exciting places it can go
so the first topic I'll tell you a little bit about maybe the most fun is
little bit about maybe the most fun is geometric folding
algorithms this the title of a a textbook and the class
textbook and the class 6849 uh and in general well there's a
6849 uh and in general well there's a lot of different kinds of folding in the
lot of different kinds of folding in the world but maybe the most accessible and
world but maybe the most accessible and fun is origami so you have on the one
fun is origami so you have on the one hand a piece of paper and you'd like to
hand a piece of paper and you'd like to turn it into some crazy threedimensional
turn it into some crazy threedimensional shape which I'm not going to try to draw
shape which I'm not going to try to draw here I don't know you want to fold a
here I don't know you want to fold a giraff or you want to make some
giraff or you want to make some geometric sculpture how do you do this
geometric sculpture how do you do this so usually you put some creases into the
so usually you put some creases into the piece of paper some reasonable
piece of paper some reasonable way uh and one of the questions is sort
way uh and one of the questions is sort of what are the rules for putting
of what are the rules for putting creases into a piece of paper when is
creases into a piece of paper when is that possible and then you'd like to uh
that possible and then you'd like to uh fold it into that shape so there're
fold it into that shape so there're really two big problems here one is
really two big problems here one is um I guess you call it
foldability and this is what you do if you practice origami in the typical way
you practice origami in the typical way you get you get origami diagrams and
you get you get origami diagrams and they say fold this you're like oh gosh
they say fold this you're like oh gosh it takes you hours to figure out how to
it takes you hours to figure out how to fold something especially if they just
fold something especially if they just gave you a crease pattern how do you can
gave you a crease pattern how do you can you even tell does it fold into anything
you even tell does it fold into anything first of all and then if so how do I do
first of all and then if so how do I do it um that problem uh folding a crease
it um that problem uh folding a crease pattern
and understanding what crease patterns are valid unfortunately is NP complete
are valid unfortunately is NP complete so there's no good way to really
so there's no good way to really understand that so origami is is hard uh
understand that so origami is is hard uh in some sense the more interesting
in some sense the more interesting Direction though is the reverse
Direction though is the reverse Direction which I would call origami
Direction which I would call origami design I have an intended 3D shape I
design I have an intended 3D shape I want to design How can I come up with
want to design How can I come up with how can I as an algorithm convert that
how can I as an algorithm convert that 3D shape into a crease pattern that does
3D shape into a crease pattern that does fold that's guaranteed to fold into that
fold that's guaranteed to fold into that 3D shape and that's actually
3D shape and that's actually solvable so design is
easier and there's all sorts of different versions of the design problem
different versions of the design problem uh some of them you can solve in
uh some of them you can solve in polinomial time some of them you can't
polinomial time some of them you can't if you really want sort of optimal
if you really want sort of optimal design that can be empty complete again
design that can be empty complete again but in particular uh there's a way to
but in particular uh there's a way to fold uh any 3D shape you want so there's
fold uh any 3D shape you want so there's an algorithm the coolest one right now
an algorithm the coolest one right now is called orgamis it's free software
is called orgamis it's free software online by tomachi and you give it a 3D
online by tomachi and you give it a 3D model of a
model of a polyhedron and it outputs a giant crease
polyhedron and it outputs a giant crease pattern on a square piece of paper that
pattern on a square piece of paper that folds into that 3D polyhedron and it's
folds into that 3D polyhedron and it's reasonably
reasonably practical and he's folded tons of models
practical and he's folded tons of models in that way
in that way um let's
see show you some other things uh here's a simple example of a geometric uh
a simple example of a geometric uh origami model so this is folded from a
origami model so this is folded from a square of paper with uh concentric
square of paper with uh concentric squares as creases alternating Mountain
squares as creases alternating Mountain and Valley so you can see Mountain
and Valley so you can see Mountain Valley Mountain Valley also fold the
Valley Mountain Valley also fold the diagonals it's very easy to make and
diagonals it's very easy to make and what's funny what's cool about it is
what's funny what's cool about it is that when you put all those creases in
that when you put all those creases in it pops into this 3D shape which for
it pops into this 3D shape which for many years people conjectured was a
many years people conjectured was a hyperbolic parabol this design is one of
hyperbolic parabol this design is one of the earliest geometric origami designs
the earliest geometric origami designs it goes back to the late 20s in the bow
it goes back to the late 20s in the bow house uh School of Design and it's it's
house uh School of Design and it's it's very cool people have folded them a lot
very cool people have folded them a lot I've personally folded thousands of them
I've personally folded thousands of them uh for sculpture and things we also do a
uh for sculpture and things we also do a lot of algorithmic sculpture uh which I
lot of algorithmic sculpture uh which I won't talk about in detail here but uh
won't talk about in detail here but uh we discovered two years ago that this
we discovered two years ago that this does not exist it is impossible to fold
does not exist it is impossible to fold a square piece of paper with this crease
a square piece of paper with this crease pattern that was a bit of a surprise and
pattern that was a bit of a surprise and it's kind of fun to make things that
it's kind of fun to make things that don't exist so what is
don't exist so what is this well uh somehow physics physical
this well uh somehow physics physical world is is differing from The Real
world is is differing from The Real World now some ways it might be
World now some ways it might be differing are that the uh these creases
differing are that the uh these creases might not be creases in the technical
might not be creases in the technical sense a crease is a place that should be
sense a crease is a place that should be non-differentiable so maybe they're kind
non-differentiable so maybe they're kind of rounding it out and then who knows
of rounding it out and then who knows what's happening then kind of all bets
what's happening then kind of all bets are off another possibility what I think
are off another possibility what I think is happening is that there extra creases
is happening is that there extra creases in here that you don't see they're very
in here that you don't see they're very small if you look especially at like the
small if you look especially at like the the Ed the raw edge here and that
the Ed the raw edge here and that profile it's a little bit wavy and it's
profile it's a little bit wavy and it's conceivable there's some points here
conceivable there's some points here that look non-differentiable to me and I
that look non-differentiable to me and I always thought that was just I wasn't
always thought that was just I wasn't folding it well enough but in fact
folding it well enough but in fact something like that has to happen and
something like that has to happen and that's my conjecture is if you look at
that's my conjecture is if you look at this under microscope which we haven't
this under microscope which we haven't done yet there are little creases that
done yet there are little creases that are are so shallow they're hard to see
are are so shallow they're hard to see but are there and the theorem says they
but are there and the theorem says they have some creases have to be there it is
have some creases have to be there it is possible to fold this with extra creases
possible to fold this with extra creases but not with
but not with these okay so get rid of that uh on the
these okay so get rid of that uh on the other hand if you do the same thing with
other hand if you do the same thing with concentric circular creases this is a
concentric circular creases this is a little harder to unfold it really wants
little harder to unfold it really wants to be in this kind of pringle shape um
to be in this kind of pringle shape um this also is from the bow house uh it's
this also is from the bow house uh it's a little harder to fold concentric
a little harder to fold concentric circles but this we think does
circles but this we think does exist uh can't prove it yet so we've
exist uh can't prove it yet so we've done a lot of sculpture based on on
done a lot of sculpture based on on these guys uh what what else do I want
these guys uh what what else do I want to
to say a yeah another demo so here's a fun
say a yeah another demo so here's a fun problem this is a magic trick goes back
problem this is a magic trick goes back to Houdini and others so imagine I take
to Houdini and others so imagine I take a rectangle of paper and then I fold it
a rectangle of paper and then I fold it flat and take my scissors it's not
flat and take my scissors it's not strict origami here and I make one
strict origami here and I make one complete straight
cut okay in this case I get two pieces and I unfold the pieces and the question
and I unfold the pieces and the question is what shapes can I get out of those
is what shapes can I get out of those pieces so in this casee I get a
pieces so in this casee I get a swan you're not impressed so I'll do
swan you're not impressed so I'll do another one uh make one straight cut
another one uh make one straight cut these are on my web page if you want to
these are on my web page if you want to impress all your
friends uh and you could take the class if you want to know how it's done this
if you want to know how it's done this is
is uh this example has a line of symmetry
uh this example has a line of symmetry you get a little angelfish okay uh I
you get a little angelfish okay uh I only have one more example I hope you're
only have one more example I hope you're you'll be impressed uh this is very hard
you'll be impressed uh this is very hard to fold
to fold it was a it was an MIT Spotlight picture
it was a it was an MIT Spotlight picture at some
at some point and it's even harder to
point and it's even harder to cut straight
cut so this should be the MIT logo all
right so the theorem is there's an algorithm given any set of polygons in
algorithm given any set of polygons in the plane you can fold make one straight
the plane you can fold make one straight cut get exactly those polygons there's
cut get exactly those polygons there's some limits in practice because of paper
some limits in practice because of paper thickness but in theory you can do
thickness but in theory you can do everything all right fun stuff
everything all right fun stuff um yeah I don't think I have time to
um yeah I don't think I have time to talk about self assembly let me talk a
talk about self assembly let me talk a little bit about data structures because
little bit about data structures because conveniently sery Drew this diagram for
conveniently sery Drew this diagram for me and I have the exact same diagram the
me and I have the exact same diagram the left one though I'm oldfashioned
uh so the models of computation we've used
so the models of computation we've used in this class are pretty simple we have
in this class are pretty simple we have in particular the word Ram you can read
in particular the word Ram you can read a word you can add two words do whatever
a word you can add two words do whatever you want with constant number of words
you want with constant number of words send them out to main memory
send them out to main memory everything's the same amount of time I
everything's the same amount of time I mean it's all a constant anyway so who
mean it's all a constant anyway so who cares except there's this issue in real
cares except there's this issue in real computers and it gets even worse with
computers and it gets even worse with parallel but let's stick to uh
parallel but let's stick to uh sequential
sequential old-fashioned
old-fashioned computers uh so you have this slow
computers uh so you have this slow bottleneck between main memory and cash
bottleneck between main memory and cash cash is really fast think of this is a
cash is really fast think of this is a really fat pipe and this is a very thin
really fat pipe and this is a very thin pipe what do we do we'd like to always
pipe what do we do we'd like to always work with things in cash but that's kind
work with things in cash but that's kind of difficult uh at some point you run
of difficult uh at some point you run out of space you got to go to main
out of space you got to go to main memory and maybe to disk other levels of
memory and maybe to disk other levels of the memory hierarchy so what systems do
the memory hierarchy so what systems do is when you fetch something from memory
is when you fetch something from memory you don't just get one word you get an
you don't just get one word you get an entire cach
entire cach line and cach lines are getting bigger
line and cach lines are getting bigger and bigger but these happen memory
and bigger but these happen memory transfers happen in
memory so let's say B is the size of a block there is another model of
block there is another model of computation that's sort of more
computation that's sort of more sophisticated than the word Rand says uh
sophisticated than the word Rand says uh how should my running time depend on B
how should my running time depend on B how many memory transfers do I need to
how many memory transfers do I need to do as a function of B and
do as a function of B and N and so for example if you want to do
N and so for example if you want to do search normally we think of doing binary
search normally we think of doing binary search that takes log and aises if
search that takes log and aises if everything is uniform but with this
everything is uniform but with this asymmetry and if you're reading in
asymmetry and if you're reading in entire blocks if you do it right you can
entire blocks if you do it right you can do it in uh log base B of
do it in uh log base B of n instead of log base 2 this is counting
n instead of log base 2 this is counting memory transfers not computation
memory transfers not computation computation here is
computation here is free it's a little weird but you get
free it's a little weird but you get used to it uh
used to it uh sorting another classic just to give you
sorting another classic just to give you an idea of how this gets a little
an idea of how this gets a little complicated you get n / btimes log base
complicated you get n / btimes log base C of n / B C is the number of blocks
C of n / B C is the number of blocks that fit in
that fit in here so there's C different blocks that
here so there's C different blocks that fit in your
fit in your cache that's the optimal way to sort
cache that's the optimal way to sort upper and lower bounds In the comparison
upper and lower bounds In the comparison model uh just to give you a flavor and
model uh just to give you a flavor and there's a whole study of algorithms that
there's a whole study of algorithms that do this what's really cool is you can
do this what's really cool is you can achieve these bounds even if you don't
achieve these bounds even if you don't know what B is and if you don't know
know what B is and if you don't know what c is there's one algorithm that
what c is there's one algorithm that whatever the architecture is underlying
whatever the architecture is underlying it will still achieve the same bound as
it will still achieve the same bound as they're called cach oblivious algorithms
they're called cach oblivious algorithms and they were invented here at
and they were invented here at MIT
MIT um yeah I think I W to all right this is
um yeah I think I W to all right this is this is too much fun to pass up on the
this is too much fun to pass up on the word
Ram there's this problem which we've dealt with several times what if you
dealt with several times what if you want to uh maintain a dynamic set of
want to uh maintain a dynamic set of elements integers I want to do insert
elements integers I want to do insert delete predecessor
delete predecessor successor okay this is what binary
successor okay this is what binary search trees do but you can do
search trees do but you can do better uh if we have integers n
integers uh in the range 0 to uus 1 so U is the size of the
is the size of the universe then
universe then uh we can achieve we already know how to
uh we can achieve we already know how to do log n but you can do two bounds one
do log n but you can do two bounds one is log log
is log log U this is a data structure called Venom
U this is a data structure called Venom deas and you can also do and it's in
deas and you can also do and it's in clrs if you're interested you can also
clrs if you're interested you can also do
do log log n divided log log
log log n divided log log U this is a data structure called Fusion
U this is a data structure called Fusion trees and it's an advanced data
trees and it's an advanced data structure 6 851 if you're
structure 6 851 if you're interested and you can take the Min of
interested and you can take the Min of those two these are that's essentially
those two these are that's essentially the best possible this is a matching
the best possible this is a matching lower bound that that's all you can
lower bound that that's all you can achieve and so just to State it in terms
achieve and so just to State it in terms in terms that you
in terms that you know just normal n bounds you take the
know just normal n bounds you take the Min of those two things they are always
Min of those two things they are always at
n compare that with log n it's way better a whole square root better and a
better a whole square root better and a little tiny savings better and this is
little tiny savings better and this is optimal it's a function of n that's the
optimal it's a function of n that's the best you can do for the predecessor
best you can do for the predecessor problem so pretty crazy stuff it's a
problem so pretty crazy stuff it's a very complicated data structures
very complicated data structures probably completely impractical but hey
probably completely impractical but hey they're theoretically pretty cool
they're theoretically pretty cool um tell you a little bit about graph
algorithms we've seen a lot of graph algorithms in this class one way to make
algorithms in this class one way to make them new and fun again
them new and fun again is to suppose your graph is planer or
is to suppose your graph is planer or almost planer meaning you can draw it in
almost planer meaning you can draw it in two Dimensions without any Crossings as
two Dimensions without any Crossings as you might get from a graph that's drawn
you might get from a graph that's drawn on the
on the earth uh like a road Network or
earth uh like a road Network or something with with no or few overpasses
something with with no or few overpasses then you can do things a lot better for
then you can do things a lot better for example you can do the equivalent of
example you can do the equivalent of Dyer's algorithm so non- negative weight
Dyer's algorithm so non- negative weight shortest paths in linear
time that's not so impressive because D is like number of edges so here I mean
is like number of edges so here I mean number of vertices it doesn't really
number of vertices it doesn't really matter with planer graphs and we had e
matter with planer graphs and we had e log V this you can write e here if you
log V this you can write e here if you prefer it's only a log savings more
prefer it's only a log savings more impressive is you can do it with
impressive is you can do it with negative weights the equivalent of
negative weights the equivalent of belman
time so some log factors log squ n divid by log log n it's the best bound known
by log log n it's the best bound known to date that's a result from last year
to date that's a result from last year so it's still work in progress uh if and
so it's still work in progress uh if and if you're interested in this kind of
if you're interested in this kind of stuff you should check out the videos
stuff you should check out the videos for the class we just taught 6
for the class we just taught 6 889 and recreational algorithms I've
889 and recreational algorithms I've actually already told you about a lot of
actually already told you about a lot of these like uh algorithms for solving
these like uh algorithms for solving Rubik's Cube and N squ divided by log n
Rubik's Cube and N squ divided by log n steps that was a paper this year uh
steps that was a paper this year uh Tetris is MP complete whole bunch of MP
Tetris is MP complete whole bunch of MP completeness and X time completeness and
completeness and X time completeness and so on results for games uh other fun
so on results for games uh other fun stuff like balloon twisting algorithms
stuff like balloon twisting algorithms for design in how to balloon twist a
for design in how to balloon twist a given polyhedron uh optimally using the
given polyhedron uh optimally using the fewest balloons algorithmic magic tricks
fewest balloons algorithmic magic tricks there's tons of stuff out there it's
there's tons of stuff out there it's really fun I should teach a class about
really fun I should teach a class about some of those things but I haven't yet
some of those things but I haven't yet um the last thing we wanted to do is
um the last thing we wanted to do is together and uh it has to do with these
together and uh it has to do with these these uh getting rid of these these
these uh getting rid of these these cushion getting rid of these damn
cushion getting rid of these damn cushions we have so many of these
cushions we have so many of these cushions just got to get rid of
cushions just got to get rid of them
them all right that's two freebies we going
all right that's two freebies we going to yeah that was you're going to have to
to yeah that was you're going to have to pay for these Christian you he's kidding
pay for these Christian you he's kidding he's kidding actually we're having
he's kidding actually we're having trouble we're having trouble giving them
trouble we're having trouble giving them away because I don't know some people
away because I don't know some people seem to not like them very much and
seem to not like them very much and neither do we so uh we we wanted to give
neither do we so uh we we wanted to give you some motivation for why why you why
you some motivation for why why you why you really need some of these cushions
you really need some of these cushions right all right so so we actually
right all right so so we actually prepared a top 10 list yeah this is this
prepared a top 10 list yeah this is this is the top 10 users of 66 cushions okay
is the top 10 users of 66 cushions okay and we're going to alternate here so
and we're going to alternate here so number 10 uh you can sit on it and get
number 10 uh you can sit on it and get guaranteed inspiration in constant
guaranteed inspiration in constant time don't forget to bring one for the
time don't forget to bring one for the final exam highly recommended uh number
final exam highly recommended uh number nine all right you can use it as a
nine all right you can use it as a frisbee you've seen that before except
frisbee you've seen that before except you cut you cut it into a circle you cut
you cut you cut it into a circle you cut it into a circle and it works really
it into a circle and it works really well
well okay we had fun with the band saw last
okay we had fun with the band saw last night number eight number eight uh you
night number eight number eight uh you can sell it as a limited edition
can sell it as a limited edition collectible on
collectible on eBay it's never ever going to be made
eBay it's never ever going to be made again
again soed this in five years 10 years yeah at
soed this in five years 10 years yeah at least five bucks I don't know
least five bucks I don't know right number seven number seven okay so
right number seven number seven okay so if you had two of these you could stick
if you had two of these you could stick them like this and remove the
them like this and remove the branding and use it as a regular
branding and use it as a regular cushion no one will ever know you took
cushion no one will ever know you took this class that's great you just need
this class that's great you just need two motivation to have
two motivation to have multiple number six number six uh it's a
multiple number six number six uh it's a holiday conversation
holiday conversation starter and conversation stopper
exactly all right number five ASM totically optimal we had to use that
totically optimal we had to use that term of course acoustic paneling yeah
term of course acoustic paneling yeah this a suggestion from a student you
this a suggestion from a student you just need a lot of them that's right
just need a lot of them that's right this would be great for piano guitar
this would be great for piano guitar fingering practice you know you're doing
fingering practice you know you're doing your DP
your DP D all right number four number four you
D all right number four number four you can use it as target practice for your
can use it as target practice for your next lar session that's
right whoa whoa Miss fire a I'm missing you haven't hit me
one all right number three all right 10 years from now it might be all you'll
years from now it might be all you'll remember
about6 you in truth you might also remember this top 10
remember this top 10 list all right number two number two you
list all right number two number two you can use it as your uh final exam cheat
can use it as your uh final exam cheat sheet this is a new rule instead of 8
sheet this is a new rule instead of 8 and 1 half by
and 1 half by 11 you could bring in uh the appropriate
11 you could bring in uh the appropriate number of cushions and the number one
number of cushions and the number one number one use for A6 cushion three
number one use for A6 cushion three words okay Cupid profile
picture all right well don't use this seat sheet but come to the final exam
seat sheet but come to the final exam and good luck thanks